ils ont fait beaucoup de bruit plus de
400 jeunes venus principalement de
croissy sur seine se sont rendus ce
lundi matin à clairefontaine pour un
entraînement de l'équipe de france
féminine a rendez vous programmé quatre
jours seulement avant leur premier match
de coupe du monde
j'aime bien envie de crier allez les
bleus c'est bien si on les voit pas tous
les jours chez les professionnels allez
les bleus s'est passé des choses
professionnel s'est passé c'est
magnifique thème donne envie de devenir
pauvre ville sélectionnée par la fifa
croissy-sur-seine recevra les bleus
pendant la coupe du monde pour créer
l'effervescence la commune n'a pas
hésité à affréter plusieurs bus pour
emmener des jeunes à la session d'avoir
la joie d'avoir deux enfants heureux
c'est pour ça qu'on a accueilli l'équipe
de france c'est pour transmettre ses
valeurs de ce sport et d'amour et de
joie que l'on retrouve ici dans un stade
après les tribunes direction les
terrains la matinée s'est terminée par
une séance de dédicaces avec les
joueuses tous ont voulu un souvenir de
cette journée de la compétition approche
plus plus agrandi pour iliad
effervescents son club
c'est bien pour nous ce positif les
enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie donc
on prend c'est bien ça fait plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge on rêvait quoi
de ça après avoir rencontré les jeunes
de croissy sur seine les bleus fouleront
pour la première fois la pelouse du
stade omnisports de la ville ce jeudi
six joueurs pendant l'entraînement à
huis clos avant leur premier match
contre la corée du sud